do you have to love your idea or is
liking it enough i'm gonna answer that
in today's ask evan
so i got a great question from one of my
loyal youtube subscribers love you guys
crap stuff wrote him to say man i gotta
be honest this advice scares me a bit if
you walk around and only think you have
to do what you really love to reach
success then it might set you on low
limits i mean would it be a failure if i
try an idea i'd like and don't really
love have you been working on something
you just like and the end results became
a success and is it somehow possible to
change like to love before you start
with the business this is a fantastic
question and
i do a lot of things that i like to do
but if you want to have a lot of success
you've got to love it and the reason is
you're not going to put in the work
you're not going to put into creativity
you're not going to put any effort on
something that you just like
so let me explain if you have an idea
that you like you're gonna show up to
the office you might work your nine to
five or whatever it is you put in the
time
but then when you come home you shut off
because you just liked it and it's just
okay but if you love something you love
an idea you love something that you're
working on you're going to be thinking
about it on the ride home you're going
to be thinking about it all night you're
dreaming about it you're telling your
friends about it you're telling your
family about it you love it right it
consumes you that's how you create
something with amazing success if you
don't have that energy you don't have
that passion
then it'll just be okay it'll be
mediocre you can make some money off of
it but you're not going to end up doing
something huge and so if the goal is to
have a major impact make a lot of money
be really successful then it has to be
chasing something that you love to do
and not just like so let me give you a
personal example in the context of the
youtube channel because you guys are
watching these videos and you know what
it's all about
i love my youtube channel that's why i
do this right i do it for you guys i
love the comments coming in i love
watching the videos myself and they
inspire me as well and if i didn't love
it i would have stopped because it's a
ton of effort a ton of time a huge chunk
of my calendar to make this stuff work
and within my youtube schedule i'm
constantly tweaking and evaluating and
putting new ideas in the example that i
can come up with now is i'm looking at
my enspresso series where i really felt
like this was missing i really felt like
it was needed to have something in the
morning to kick start your day as an
entrepreneur to get some ideas to help
you think bigger i needed it for myself
because i felt like i was still limiting
myself from where i could go and as a
result the espresso series has been
amazing my youtube subscribers are going
to be my best month ever by a huge
margin my views is the best month ever
by a huge margin and it's because i
really loved it i poured so much thought
and energy and creativity into it and
and it's great that the results are
coming in if i just liked it though
i wouldn't have put as much effort into
it and there are some other series on my
channel that i've dropped off because i
liked them yeah they were good but
they were just good
and just good
isn't enough if you want to have a lot
of success
so can you have success if you just like
something
yeah you can have a little you could be
mediocre you can have average success
like most people most people
don't even like what they're doing so
you'll be a little bit more successful
than them
but if you want to have major success
which i hope is what i'm helping inspire
on this channel then you have to do
something that you love and you can even
start off loving something loving
something tons of passion energy and
then the love fades
that's also super common and at that
point you want to move on sell that
business move on to something else
always follow your flow always follow
your passion always follow what you are
excited to do because that's where your
awesomeness is going to come out
believe thank you guys for watching i'd
love to know your thoughts do you have
to love what you do to be a success
leave it in the comments below i'm going
to join in the discussion thank you for
watching and i'll see you soon